with cannabis lounges now legal in
nevada many are wondering when exactly
they will open up the nevada cannabis
compliance board says they're getting
everything ready for that to happen joe
mohler here he sat down with the board's
executive director and has more on a
potential timeline o'brien many in the
industry are waiting for that green
light to apply for their lounge license
and the board director says they are
working to make sure everything is in
place before lounges can open up
we were the first dispensary to open in
city of las vegas
frank hawkins is one of the owners of
nevada wellness center this is the
consumption lounge
that has been ready for about two years
despite it being legal he can't open
this lounge just yet not until
regulation has been created by the new
ccb we sat down with the executive
director of the ccb or cannabis
compliance board tyler klimas if
everything goes well we'll probably see
the first consumption lounges open up
mid-year next year from public safety to
health concerns klamas says the board is
working on the rules and regulations
needed for the lounges a lot of that has
to do with the licensing
and the application of consumption
lounges they expect the application
period to open in the spring the process
could take a few months
existing dispensaries can apply to add a
lounge for a hundred thousand dollar
non-refundable application fee 20
independent lounges will be permitted
for a smaller not yet determined fee
half of those independent lounges per
the legislation
will be held and awarded to social
equity applicants further increasing the
in inclusiveness and diversity the board
is still figuring out exactly who will
qualify as a social equity applicant
then you'll come in front of the board
and you'll address the board and the
board will either deem you suitable or
not suitable to open a license
klima says those in the industry can get
updates through workshops and or public
meetings they expect to have a large
universal meeting about these rules and
regulations coming up in december i'll
send it back to you guys